let's go to the last story this this
last story is one of these my gosh this
guy yep here's the story alright here's
the video have you guys seen this video
look look at her earring
this woman tweeted here's a great
jackhole
he was angry that I reclined my seat and
punched it about nine times hard at
which point I began videoing him and he
resigned to this behavior the other
jackhole is the American air flight
attendant who reprimanded me and offered
him rum Oh seriously
so here's what's happening on for those
are just listening a woman on a plane is
in the second-to-last row the man
sitting behind her can't recline she
reclines back he apparently doesn't like
that she did so he starts punching the
back of her seat like a two-year-old I'm
biased by the way you can tell whose
side I'm on I am on he's just punching
your seat over and over again like a
spoiled little brat this story annoyed
me oh man it annoyed me yes I used to
fly two flights per week that's
ridiculous and everybody knows if you
pick the toilet seat you know then you
can't recline yep so then you're mad
someone else didn't buy the toilet seat
so you're gonna start punching the back
of their seat I swear to god this guy I
don't know how old he is but I'll tell
you what man these people today they are
children yeah maybe that's a channel
children that's what it looks like it
looks like a little whiny baby little
toddler yep being upset poor baby did
buy the ba ba boo boo seat I wasn't
lying to ya do what she's doing
yeah when I first saw this video I
thought that this guy had a mental
difficulty but that mental difficult but
then but that's he doing yeah well then
the the guy the flight attendant offers
him rum what that is we're sorry I tell
you story Oh with this customer that's
reclining in our seats that we gave her
that recline like let me let me tell you
a story what I mean let me tell you I
got I can't stand it's up you know why I
used to fly two times a week okay I
would fly everywhere all the time mostly
nationally spike when I worked for Vice
it was it was less frequently but often
internationally so with Vice it was like
1.5 times a week so like every two weeks
you know two or three flights with
fusion twice a week there was one time
I was in first class I always go to
board first for a few reasons I have
cameras in my backpack right which means
if I don't get overhead bin space and
they tried to put my backpack in the
carriage it will break the cameras right
lesson number one
I was III had a sneak sort of I was
trying to board a regional flight out of
New Zealand okay and they said no carry
ons allowed so I had to like hold it
behind me so they couldn't see it
because I had a thirty thousand dollar
camera in that backpack it will break
yeah they will break it so Amin I'm in
the front of this line to go and board
in first class so I can i've guaranteed
space it's paid for by the business and
these old people assumed probably
because I'm wearing a you know hoody and
a beanie I'm just blocking their way and
cut in front of me so when they say
we're born in first class lo and behold
they were business and I have to walk
past them oh they got real angry about
that sir so I'm I walk in and they're
like hey hey you cutting us and the
woman booking me in she's like I don't
know and I showed her my ticket she's
like no you're not and so when I walk in
eventually I get up too so that when
they do boarding they do globe it's it's
it was American Airlines so it's
concierge key which are like business
elite connections yeah Americans name
it's beyond first-class right military
personnel and the elderly so I'm
standing there were still in a line on
the jet bridge because although they're
boarding first-class there were still
some people in front of me okay the
woman comes up behind me and shoves me
what and I get pushed forward and then I
immediately I'm like no way and
everyone's like murmuring like oh what
happened and then the old guy threatens
me says he was gonna he was gonna hit me
so I go to the I go to the the flight
and I said that woman just shoved me
those people will tell you what happened
and that guy's threatening to hit me
they said we're gonna kick both of you
off the plane you guys know me and I
said this woman hit me yeah we're doing
anything about it and she goes oh yeah
we'll call the police and then we'll
take you off the flight and then the
police can come and you can file a
report and I said those people just like
people backed me up saying yeah she hit
him she walked up from walking behind me
and hit me right and they were like we
don't care and I was
so you think it's a good idea to put us
both in this plane right now yeah and
you're threatening me that if I ask
elate this you're gonna kick you're not
gonna me to find this plane and they're
like yep so I had no choice
to just go on the plane and sit down and
she set we were both in first class she
had because you are so I was in first
and she was in business and it's like
yeah there's a small separation because
there's like right yes there was like
there's like I think six pods and then
behind it is the is the business seats
and so she was complaining the entire
time and other people were upset saying
this lady's unhinged and we're gonna be
in a plane with her and it sounded like
it wasn't even you it sounded like she
just was having a really bad day I just
I'd you know man the fact that she the
this woman in the seat or isn't
reclining and the guys punching are like
a whiny baby dick yeah and the airline
would defend it doesn't surprise me at
all that's doesn't doesn't surprise me
at all what is it about being in
enclosed spaces that make us makes us
act like children like that's not a good
snow it's something's wrong with you no
I don't know what other generations were
like maybe there were always this dumb
and whiny and pathetic you know what and
this is what I say about everything
there's always a person like that in all
different types of races and ages
there's always those a-holes there's
always the cool people there's always
there's all these different types of
people across all different you know
varieties so like this is just one of
the child's that you know grew up in
snow bass listen you agree with me that
the guy in the back punching the seats
the bad guy absolutely okay now take a
look take a look to us they were both
wrong etiquette expert William Hanson
declares his verdict on the american
airlines seat punching incident the
divided social media the passenger wendy
williams was flying from New Orleans to
Charlotte she filmed a passenger blah
blah blah she reclined her seat punched
it and then she video shamed him hey how
about he just go hey look I'm feeling a
little claustrophobic would you mind
reclining a little less no why why not
well what's wrong with that because you
pick the toilet seat no I know but
wouldn't he punched it over and over
again that was his first she just
reclined she's not even thinking about
this dude right she's thinking I'm
saying you know actually I'm gonna watch
this movie I'm getting comfortable boom
she starts getting punched like the sea
kitten punched he could have tried it
well he he maybe did and she said no and
she's justified it's actually I agree
with you she is justified it you know
she's sitting in a reclining seat why
he's not why did the airline let those
seats recline then why yeah it's a good
question it's like if you're if you're
gonna defend this dude make those seats
not able to recline so the people that
can't recline in the back dude
everybody knows chairs recline everybody
know mates at once can and they tell you
when you booked a ticket this seat can't
recline you know the exit wrote the so
the so in the exit rows you have to
though the one in front can't recline
because it would block the racks are
behind it exactly right but the second
exit row can right which is one of the
baskets got extra legroom yeah that's
nice so you you need to know these
things
you bought a product you paid for a
ticket you were given your garbage
toilet seat that you paid for I've flown
the toilet seat man I call it toilet
seat because the toys literally behind
him yeah yeah exactly
or it could be a closet but it's
typically the toilet seat right all
right it always smells bad but they cost
dirt its basic economy so cheese cheese
you like it you can good yup so when you
got to fly in a budget that's did you
get this dude nah not having it and I
haven't and you have you have a lot of
people like he look he looks like his
tall guy there's no justifying this now
as for the for the for the shaming thing
that's what they're arguing here that
she social media she was just shocked
that it happened to not look man she's
like this is happy that's the best thing
she could have done I'm just gonna film
it yep I agree and you know what that's
actually something that used to be a
thing public shaming I don't know you
know but there's a difference
well I ensure on disguising being
physical with her yeah and so he's
assaulting and by her just filming it
that was the right move if somebody on
the street and they're and they're
screwing with you and you film it
there's probably other things you can do
you could defend yourself if someone's
actually getting physical with you but
filming it is one of the better moves
because it shows that you're not trying
to ask like things physically that's
true it shows they're the aggressor yeah
you gotta you got to be tactful on this
he was just bewildered that this guy is
actually punching her seat she's like
what else am I gonna do I'm just gonna
document it like look buddy give the
crazy eyes go back up go back up look at
the crazy eyes
he's got crazy eyes man so we're in my
idle whiny babies entitled entitled yeah
she wrongs don't make it right what are
you talking about I don't know what she
did wrong look at this woman said if I
paid I paid if I paid for a seat I'll
work on if I want to mm-hmm but they're
actually people look at this I'm six
foot five and can't stand inconsiderate
people putting their seats back being
the size I am I still won't recline due
to having courtesy of others if it was
me you wouldn't have got your seat back
so count yourself lucky this guy let you
sew my like dude don't care sorry bro
don't care dude just because you're
bigger than someone else means that I
don't get the seat I paid for now I
didn't buy a seat like American Airlines
didn't say by the way a six foot five
guy will be up behind you so you lose
the right to recline yeah basically your
height is not my issue that is not my
fault I bought a ticket for me I get to
recline it for you yeah we have what we
have a whiny baby generation man you
know I want to talk about I'm gonna talk
about something else about flight
etiquette you know when people go and
grab the chair in front of them to pull
themselves up and oh dude I use it Oh
like I have long hair you guys probably
noticed and like I've had my hair pulled
out like pieces of my hair get pulled
because like someone gets a piece of my
hair and they just like pull themselves
up and I'm like pull my hair and uh yeah
obviously I get aggravated at this and
it's like why don't you use your own
seat behind you push yourself up and
you're good use your arm wrestle use
your armrest I can't stand it they grab
the back of the end of my seat and pull
so me all the way back I get so
aggravated when that happened man it's
happened so many people just think that
they can just grab a head because it's
there and it's like pay attention
there's someone's face right there like
this guy's punching it it's the same
thing too this is why I always changin
I'll tell you we want you to come out
for our show we want you to come on on
my climbing first class yeah and then
guess what they always do because they
know it's like when when you're flying
out for professional reasons now I'll
say there's flying vais infusion I did
fly first-class whole time only because
of frequent flyer miles yeah cuz you
earned status but they will never give
you first-class and that to me is nuts
it's like dude if you want me to fly
overnight
to Turkey for a conflict zone right you
want me sitting in a boo boo seat where
I can't sleep guess I'm losing a day at
work but when it comes to this stuff
dude it flying you know some people
really enjoy it but the food's often
really bad fly business if you can yeah
they're actually like a little status
point those same videos that they play
every single time at the beginning that
I don't even listen to anymore because I
can almost do it word-for-word for them
all but Virgin America's awesome should
have I'm sure there's some there is some
goods awesome you like humor ones out
there but like you know there should be
some aggregate advice talking about
etiquette right general etiquette on the
plane if your baby is crying put it in a
plastic bag and tie the bag shut I'm
kidding
don't do that joke and naughty joke oh
man
actually tie this back to what we were
talking about yesterday with
self-awareness yeah yeah like a little
boom I keep my arms in I'm kind of tall
so I need to like be aware of what I'm
doing all the time I'm not gonna be
grabbing the back of someone's chair I'm
not gonna be for their face I mean there
is something about the the elbow thing
it's like if you're in the window you
got to you can lean against the window
you can get all you know but if you're
in the middle you get you should have a
little bit of elbow room or is it the
roll that's the rule knows their rules
on their rules on the elbow thing flight
etiquette mm-hmm is that if you have a
window seat
yeah then the left arm rest is yours if
you have an aisle seat the right arm
rest is yours and the person the middle
gets both armrests s' that's like two
and 'red flight etiquette that's what
that's what I think I agree with that
completely but we haven't we have a
generation of whiny entitled babies who
think everything belongs to them yeah
it's like dude I'm gonna sit in my seat
I'm gonna lean as far away from you as I
can to give you space that's exactly
what I do I'm just like I try to stay in
my zone I you know I don't want to
interrupt you know it and just get to
the next spot you know was one of the
craziest flights I've ever been on I was
sitting I says dude who was morbidly
obese okay and and and it was
encroaching on my seat yeah like his
body yeah and you know what I'm like
look it's a two-hour flight yeah it's
very uncomfortable because I can feel
his hot yeah large body pressing against
me but that's okay that actually happy
cuz when I flew back here but hold on
let go god I can tolerate certain things
why I'm a mature adult so I said you
know what there's nothing
do about it he smelled bad too but you
don't made it worse but the food [ __ ]
the food cart came would you like to
purchase any foods or snack food or
snacks or beverages and I said I'll have
a water please and you sir oh hello what
what was that is that I'll have it I'll
have a cheese box and is that a turkey
sale - give me the turkey sandwich and
and the the the wrap the chicken wrap
I'll give me two cans of coke and is
that Pringles I'll take three of those I
could you know I'm not kidding I was
just like bro that's nuts
yeah and he'd set there for the entire
flight just eating this massive food
everywhere up I'm like am both him
whatever no no no no no that was food
everywhere a terrible smell and I'm
being pressed up against my seat and you
know that's that's like this it's an
interesting conundrum if American
Airlines told me mm-hmm we sold the seat
next to you to a morbidly obese
individual I'd say I'd like to move my
seat yeah but someone's got to sit there
yeah so when I flew back here last week
or two weeks ago I I was in NOAA when I
flew back to put it back home so I'm in
an emergency aisle and I'm like oh great
I'm in the middle seat I'm like yeah
it's an emergency you know I'll have the
extra legroom like it's fine so I sit
down and sure enough it's that six foot
five guy that's huge on my left and he's
he's muscular he's huge big huge dude
and it's the same thing you know like
there's no way I can sit without his
body just touching me and it's hot and
it's uncomfortable and I'm like you know
what it's okay I like I I didn't even
have access to the left like I was on
the right side of the plane so like he
was just in the aisle and he was just so
big I couldn't use the left thing yeah
so I'm like all right well I'll use the
right side and I try to put my Oban and
the guy in the window was like straight
faced these are both of my elbow rests
I'm not moving my elbow and I'm like
trying to like you know he like smashed
in the middle yeah smashed in the middle
and he's like he wasn't a big dude he
was a he was almost the same size as me
you know so I'm like and he's straight
up starts pushing my
oh and and I'm like what's going on dude
he's like yeah we both get to share that
and like put his hit back and I'm like
are you kidding me right now like like
do you see what I'm dealing with and the
guy over here he like he's like do we
have a problem I'm like no no the
problems not with you I'm like dude he's
a big dude can you can you give me some
room yeah and he just goes no and he
puts his headphones back on and I'm just
like what do I die don't people what do
I do in this situation you ever what I
was like no no I straight-up manhandled
my elbow in there I didn't care man and
that do you can do about it I he he
didn't do a thing
cuz you I I won that the elbow battle
you honest thing funny so if you cut in
front of a huge line like let's there's
a huge line people easily walk right to
the front yeah you know no I'll do
anything about it I I'm that guy that
would be like hey what are you doing
buddy cutting but even then and if they
stay there I'm not gonna I don't do
anything past that but I shame them
shame those people when I am that guy
though when you when you board and
you're sitting down do you like sitting
in a window seat yeah
when you see people boarding are you
ever like oh not that person okay that
person's okay no no I pretty much stay
in my own world
when I'm flying I you bad music on or
I'm just like my crab needs to play
which one of these strange creatures
will be sitting next to me yeah and so
I'm sitting in my window seat and I see
them coming in and I'm like is it gonna
be that one and then they walk past my
call thank you and then I see like some
writer looking for some like please
please be saw know they're walking past
me and then some like stinky you know
nasty person with like bring it on their
food to sit next to me in their locker
you don't mind I'm reading and what
about what about the you know the what
is that what is the Fight Club term the
single-use friends yeah yeah it's like
what if you don't want to talk what if
you don't want that single-use friend
and they're just not talking to you it
would say something with nauseous yeah
yeah I don't like talking put on my wish
put on my bottom a gap
I'll do it thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and
all our segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you